Speaker 1: A, we have seen a ton of bad analogies
during the pandemic from Republicans.
Vaccines are like Nazi medical experiments
conducted by Joseph
Speaker 2: Mengele
Speaker 1: vaccine cards proof of vaccination.
It's like a Nazi yellow star that they made
the Jews wear during the Holocaust or last
week or the week before.
We heard Sherri Tenpenny say vaccinating a
kid is like a very late term abortion because
you're killing the kid with the vaccine.
It's a very long list of these bogus analogies.
I'm not going to go through all of it right
now, but the theme is absolutely horrifying,
disgusting analogies that make no sense whatsoever.
We now have another one from radical, rabid,
reprehensible Republican ranter Marjorie Taylor
Greene, and this time she's comparing COVID
to cancer in thinking about how societally
we reacted to the pandemic.
And you might say, Wait, sir, hold on what?
How?
Huh?
Yes, she's doing it.
Marjorie Taylor Greene tweeted over the weekend,
every single year, more than 600000 people
in the U.S. die from cancer.
The country has never once shut down.
Not a single school has closed, and every
year over 600000 people of all ages and all
races will continue to die from cancer.
Now, of course, you all in the audience because
you're so smart because it's so obvious you
realize COVID is a contagious communicable
virus.
Cancer is not contagious.
That's the analysis.
That's that.
That's it.
But there is that.
There's no more analogy here, but there are.
There are some other interesting aspects to
this that I think are worth thinking about.
We do spend.
Is it millions, is it hundreds of millions?
Is it billions to try to control the development
of cancer, to try to understand what causes
it when there are cancers of known cause?
Public policy to try to prevent it?
I mean, yeah, we've got a lot of regulations
about cigarets, where you can smoke, taxing
cigarets, et cetera.
Higher life insurance cost if you smoke how
much pollution factories can point up a pump
out which causes cancer downstream?
OK, at some level, it's because it causes
cancer.
Much more to it, of course, but we do a ton
of stuff to try to stop cancer,
Speaker 2: which is not contagious.
Speaker 1: Sometimes we do close schools permanently
because of asbestos.
Right?
So even when Marjorie Taylor Greene says we
don't close schools over cancer, we kind of
do.
I mean, is it just one example?
But buildings get shut down because of asbestos,
which causes mesothelioma mesothelioma?
Given that, why wouldn't we do be doing a
ton of stuff
Speaker 2: to try to stop something
Speaker 1: like cancer that kills people?
But in this case, it's something you can get
from being sneezed or coughed on.
COVID can also kill you, and you can get it
by someone who walks by and sneezes on you,
which you can't with cancer.
And when I saw this, I thought, Man, this
is really dumb.
But then I thought, Wait a second, we should
be doing more to prevent cancer.
And interestingly, we have shut down schools,
we do do things, we pass significant public
policy.
And then I realized, Hey, you know what?
Preventing cancer is really tough, especially
for cancers that we don't yet understand the
cause of, which is many
Speaker 2: with the virus.
We know the cause.
Speaker 1: We know how it's transmitted.
Speaker 2: We have a
Speaker 1: playbook and it's a simple one.
Vaccines, masks, where appropriate, testing,
sequencing, et cetera.
We know the plan.
So in the end, yes, it's a very dumb tweet,
but it's a tweet.
Marjorie Taylor Greene thinks will get us
to say, Wow, COVID guidelines.
Speaker 2: These are bad.
Speaker 1: We shouldn't be doing any of this
stuff.
When you really think about it, layer one
is that's really stupid.
Cancer is not a communicable disease.
When you go to layer two, it makes me think,
wow.
In the case of COVID, we know exactly what
the causes are.
And still, so many people don't do the basic
things to stop its spread.
Whereas with cancer, with many cancers, we
don't know what causes it.
At the end
Speaker 2: of the day, the problem
Speaker 1: is that stupidity does seem to
be contagious.
People see these tweets, and some think that
there are good arguments and they repeat them,
and in the end, they don't get vaccinated.
They don't do the things that we're supposed
to do in order to stop the spread of this
disease.
Now, I'm not even getting into it in this
segment, we will get into it.
What's happening with COVID right now is bonkers,
and it's not even clear that it is yet because
of Omicron, we're going to get to that.
Maybe later today, maybe tomorrow.
In the meantime, more on
Speaker 2: this on our
Speaker 1: Instagram, where you can find us
at David Pakman Show.
You can also follow me on Instagram at David
Pakman.
We'll take a quick break and be right back.